though 100 100 think about that for a
second PGA Championship tees off this
morning at Belle Reve Country Club in
st. Louis fans have been lining up to
watch top golfers like Tiger Woods of
course jordan Spieth and Justin Thomas
playing the practice rounds this year
marks the 28th consecutive year that CBS
Sports has broadcast a championship
Jim Nantz of CBS 4 says anchored the PGA
Championship broadcast since 1901 look
at you Jim that's high joins us from the
course Jim good morning to you I think I
retired that time just a few years ago
yes but let's talk about do not call
human resources Jim Nanna let's talk
about Tiger Woods do you think that this
is it's cut I gir Woods is it just come
back season yeah he's played I think a
whole lot better than anyone would have
imagined he's actually gonna be teeing
off here in the next hour playing in a
very star-studded group of three with
Justin Thomas who just won this last
week in an acronym or golf championship
and Rory McIlroy and of course Tiger
flirted with winning the Open
Championship over to Carnoustie last
month so hey listen this is the 14th
time he's played this year in this
comeback season and he's performed well
he's had a hard time getting past that's
the second night on Sunday afternoon but
I don't put anything past Tiger I think
he's gonna win one of these days maybe
this will be the week I wouldn't have
him as the favorite but nothing that he
does surprises me anymore you're talking
about either the all-time greatest
player certainly in the discussion with
the Jack Nicklaus and Bobby Jones and a
few others well you mentioned Justin
Thomas do you think that he can keep his
title he wanted a year ago in Charlotte
he's coming in here fresh off a win with
all the top 50 players in the world at
Firestone and there you see he's ranked
number two in the world at just 25 years
old he's already won nine times so we
have the this is symbolic of where the
game is right now you got Tiger who's 42
which listen you can play this game
competitively until you're close to 50
Phil Mickelson is still playing well at
48 but the game has
really now been turned over it's been
handed off to this young brigade of
20-somethings and justin thomas jordan
spieth of Spieth one this week what a
story that would be he'd have the career
Grand Slam he'd close it out here the
age of 25 so the game is young and
talented and fearless and this is the
last major championship of the year
you mentioned Justin Thomas he's number
two Dustin Johnson is number one do you
consider him a contender here vlad you
listen he's I think he's the odds-on
favorite although trying to pick a golf
tournament and and and identify the the
winner in advance is a tough thing to do
not since the days of when Tiger was on
top of the world of golf was it easier
to predict someone winning a major
championship but you know Dustin he's
won three times this year most recently
up in Toronto at the RBC Canadian Open
he's got you know he just got a whole
arsenal of weapons he can hit it so far
he's got the deft touch around the green
and yeah you're looking at these World
Golf Rankings you got DJ Justin Thomas
Justin Rose Brooks kept cut for some
reason stays under the radar I think
he's gonna be tough to beat this week
and if I had to pick a guy to be the one
on the right Rory McIlroy he was close
like I just last week did not play well
on Sunday he's won four major
championships including this one twice
so that would be my pick but take it for
what it's worth oh it's worth a lot they
said we gotta go Jim but I'm not going
till we say congrats Bravo to you 2018
ambassador of golf why because they say
your legendary voice has played an
enormous ly important role in bringing
the PGA Tour to millions of homes and
that there's no better ambassador we
have in this game than Jim Nantz we say
yes yes she introduced you as an
ambassador every time you're an
ambassador I know I love lots of being
Gayle but here you read it means even
more so thank you very much all right
congrats again